hello everyone this is samir from audio
science review i have a
product review for you a very high end
deck from company called cord
it's the cord dave
you see it on right side over here and
the box itself is sitting there
uh on this thing um it's a very
expensive deck by uh you know most
standards uh fourteen thousand dollars
for the stereo deck although that prices
can go up to sixty seventy thousand
dollars believe it or not
anyway uh there's been a lot of requests
to measure this and i was fortunate
enough to connect with a member that had
it and he was kind enough to send it to
me for review
as you can imagine sending something
this expensive to someone to be tested
that
there's some risk involved and i really
appreciate the member sending it in
um i uh
uh really dislike the user invasion
other court products they have these uh
globe bubbles that change colors and you
have to
you know keep looking the manual to know
what's what and even then you may
mistakenly think you have the dac in one
setting versus the other so i was really
looking forward to this higher end
product from that has a display on it
and while the display helps a lot now
you can see that usb input is usb input
and you see the volume and everything uh
still i found it quite hard to navigate
it's got four buttons in here plus a
push
enabled rotary controller for the volume
the volume is fine more or less this is
a slippery metal globe
and almost has enough room for your
thumb to change it from top it just
feels too small and slippery to try to
change volume on it but you know it
works what doesn't work is this
constantly remembering you know how to
go change these settings in here with
four different buttons which one goes
the way which
and some of the modes at least one of
the modes requires pushing these two
simultaneously without touching
something else
um it's just
seems like a company doesn't believe in
any usability studies you know they
should put a person you know in front of
it and
and just tell them to do simple tasks to
see if they can figure out how to do it
a dax shouldn't be a complicated device
to turn on and use and change the
settings and there are companies with
just two buttons and a rotary control
that do far better job than than cord
does this display is also slanted back
as you can see from this unit over here
and uh which means if you put it on any
kind of shelf and sit back in a you know
home two channel listening space you
won't see anything of this display it
loses contrast tremendously as it goes
side uh slanted normally and you barely
can see the usb and volume control all
of these get washed out completely so
the company itself sells this 2400 stand
to tilt it and everything
or you can use it i guess on the desktop
uh on this thing so
i like the inaudible look of it with
this circular circular
you know dial in here and and the rest
of it no objection but
you know bottom line is can you get in
get out of a using a simple device like
a dac and and i don't think that's the
case in here um
it is quite heavy it weighs four
kilograms or eight or nine pounds and it
it feels that when you pick it up you
almost have to use two hands to pick it
up
on that so
um
normally just a quick caveat normally
when i measure uh products i don't take
their price into consideration because
uh you know some people can afford to
pay a lot more for audio product and you
know overlook and everything else but in
this case um the deck is very very
expensive and the designer
has the seminars left and right talks
about all the precision and perfection
of this stack that is better than any
other dac out there so
just
you know just note that i will be picky
as a result given the marketing claims
on this thing and the price
so as usual we run our uh one kilohertz
uh dashboard uh the dac the the
chord that can be put in the dac mode or
preamp mode and the only difference is
that in dac mode the output is fixed
voltage in a pre-op mode it's the same
thing but you can adjust the volume so
when you just put in dag mode it puts
out this oddball 6.2 volts i don't know
where to get this
from um the standard is four volts for
balanced output
six volts may or may not overflow uh the
uh uh downstream device uh you know if
you're gonna pick a fixed vol apple just
pick you know four volts not some about
six volts but this is typical of court
products they all have this kind of cork
in them
it helps them in an a b test if you
compare this one it act as only four
volts output this has six volts gonna
sound louder um people might prefer that
so anyway getting into the measurements
uh you know this is our one killer's
tone this is our second harmonic we see
that the two channels are very different
the blue channel versus red channel the
red channel has a lot more uh the second
harmonic distortion but something that
you can't see in here is that this noise
floor was just dancing up and down and
then it would go back to zero and dance
up and down and go back down
and this sign ad i'll show you in a
minute uh was jumping all over the place
but only in channel two but channel one
more or less was good
um
and to show you that i can't show you
the dancing around but i went ahead and
recorded the the cyanide output uh
cyanide measurement for the dac in the
two channels and you can see that the
blue channel is going along fine but the
red channel is like all over the place
in here as much as 6 db variation in
there
it's still good at 107 db so it's not
something you're probably going to hear
audibly but
you know
it definitely blows any argument about
precision and greatness of the design
there are two other measurements out
there of the stack
and they don't show this they don't have
this exact measurement
and it's possible that they saw it and
didn't plot it didn't pay attention i
don't know i can't speak for them but
i'll leave the door ever so slightly
ajar that this unit is you know
just something about this design or or
decade it's degraded or it manufactures
got a problem either way if the company
thinks this is not representative they
can send me another one and i'll measure
it i'd like that to be a random sample
from a dealer not one that they would
hand pick
to send to me but anyway very
disappointing right out the gate to have
one channel do this you know i've i went
back to verify this was not a problem
with that measurement i have a topic
d70s next to me that i use for this kind
of quick test and it's signed at 119 db
and rock solid on both channels so exact
same cables were used from power cables
to interconnect to analyze and nothing
was changed rather than just moving the
wires from that to this and results were
perfect so it's not an instrumentation
problem
on this thing
i often see this kind of problem with uh
dax that pick up noise over usb the
stack claims to have gavion isolation
meaning that even
noise polluting the ground should not
matter but
i figured i'd test that possibility by
not using usb but going with the optical
toslink now we have full electrical
isolation and uh
we're not even using usb or usb cables
unplugged and i was disappointed to see
the same modulating going up and down
going up and down and continuously
here i've got this adjusted to minus 4db
fs this 0 should say minus and to get us
4 volts to be able to compare it to
other dax and so if we go back to usb mo
input we see the same result again with
the same nose modulation now to sign out
you can see one of the instances where i
snapshot this picture where the second
channel is dropped out to 108. for
average these two
you know the dac lands in this blue uh
quartile that i call excellent but boy
for 14 000 they better be pegging the
max over here
not be worse than probably what 30 40
dax are performing better than it uh on
this thing and in the sign ad
is the same as chord mojo 2 which costs
fraction of the price of this unit so
even if we forget about the modulation
for a second and say this is a you know
sample problem uh overall performance is
not good and this by the way is
consistent with measurements others have
made as far as the sign i take it 11214
db
so best in class is 123 db sorry yeah
123 db so we're way way way off from uh
top of the line performance as far as
noise and distortion
again the company raves about caring
about the utmost detail and their signal
processing and noise modulation and
everything so we can certainly hold
their feet to the fire in here and say
look if if you cared and
left no stone unturned you should be way
up here not have this much noise and
distortion that pulls your performance
down
on this thing
it appears that the internal design is
unbalanced that there's a kind of
conversion to balance that actually has
a penalty so because the rca output is
actually a little bit cleaner it still
modulates up and down so that problem
doesn't go away and we can once again
see that it's got this odd bottle output
of 3.1 volt rather than 2 volts so again
take caution if you're doing the
listening test
comparing this stack to another dac
by far 95 percent of dioxide tests put
out two volts on there uh over rca not
3.16 um to get close go down 4 db on the
on the volume control and you get more
or less 2 volts that you can then
compare do not compare that at
the fixed volume
um it's a capable dac as far as output
it can actually go beyond what i even
showed you and goes as high as you know
almost 11 volts in here before it clips
eclipse really really bad you get a
nasty square wave with modulation at
both ends of it so do not go into the
clipping mode and
uh
don't go past plus three db um
and on the volume control it goes all
the way up to plus 9 or 10 or something
11.
but don't go past three anything past 3
db
means it will clip and will clip really
bad so stay out of that and and
performance more or less doesn't change
anyway so uh on this thing and the only
reason to use higher output is because
you have an amplifier that has a low
gain and it performs with a lower gain
unlike the benchmark
hp2 dac i mean sorry amplifier
and uh for that you do gain something so
it's nice to have that extra headroom in
there
um i went ahead run intermodulation test
um versus uh
level and this graph when it's sloping
down is noise dominated and then
at the end it becomes distortion
dominated we see that his performance
the same as one of my references which
is a top-end dx3
pro this is a three-year-old dac long
obsoleted and
yet has the same noise figure as these
250 dollars at the time and yet this uh
14 000 dac doesn't better it in noise it
only betters it in distortion when you
go at the maximum level when we have a
gap in here
around the multi-tone test uh in this
critical area it does very well 21 bits
uh you know best in class does 22 23
bits but about 20 it's 21 business
certainly very good but it's got this in
strange intermodulation tones at very
low frequencies um i don't know what's
causing that uh it could be power supply
noise or or who knows um
but uh otherwise it's very good this
drops it down to only 17 bits of
resolution which is uh nothing to write
home about
um
this linearity graph the ideal is a flat
line and you this looks almost like a
flat line but if you pay attention you
see that it's sort of wiggly
way down here till you get here you know
even 150
while performing deck will be almost
ruler flat and not have this wiggliness
in here so i think this is only good to
about 18 bits and
not above that so which is just not
competitive it should be at least uh 20
bits and if not more
i've talked a lot about noise let's
actually measure it and uh this is the
rca out
we get 113 db 112 db that's 19 bits of
dynamic range before noise takes over
it's not competitive i'll show you in a
second and
this is the xlr output this is almost
the same
but to show you a comparison this is the
moto mola
tambecki uh dac
which is priced similarly to it but it's
also a stream and look at its
performance it's also a custom single
bit deck just like this one is so it's
not built on off the shelf chips and
look at it there's 122 db in here and we
only have 113 in here that's massive
amount of noise difference and noise is
something you hear just a matter of how
far you turn up the gain on an amplifier
or how sensitive your headphones are if
you're doing headphone listening uh
distortion you may not be able to hear
but noise you will hear so in this
critical area
you know performance just not
there and is it audibly transparent to
everybody yeah this is about threshold
of hearing and so i don't expect anybody
else to listen to it so oh it was very
noisy but you know company again talks a
lot about measurements and we're not
seeing that the main thing they talk
about tremendously is this
reconstruction filter that they have and
how they use i think 160 000 taps in
there and the more taps they use the
more sharp this gets the more of the
audible band it preserves and the less
of the outer band that it lets through
but this kind of performance above 20
kilohertz is obviously most of us can't
hear 20 kilos let alone above that so
getting that to be more and more
vertical you know take it you can give
it to me it is engineering excellence
but it's not an audible excellence but
you know job is well done in that case
and attenuation is very good for
out-of-band area
it has a mysterious uh high frequency
filter that's not documented it's at the
google for it and secondhand information
it was that
it should be left on normally when you
use it uh but if you use their m scalar
resampler it doesn't you turn it off
which is very strange because if you
leave this on you get a roll off
that actually starts around two or three
kilohertz and uh by the time you get to
the up to 20 kilos you've lost almost
one db
one earth having this sharp filter
and in one breath and in next breath
recommend that people have a slow filter
added to it that chops off the response
fortunately you can turn it off and if
you turn it off you do get ruler flat
response now to 22 killers or that the
bandwidth of this measurement is a 44
kilo sampling
but
maybe that's why they don't document
that it's just impossible to justify you
know like i said needing a sharp filter
and then cascading with a slow roll off
filter
slow relatively speaking
so not good
um performance you know i've shown you a
lot of stuff at one kilohertz now we run
a test that sweeps from 20 kilos on down
to 20 hertz we get a flat response which
is good that means it has no frequency
dependency but this this line should be
way down here state-of-the-art dax are
around this .03
and because it's got extra noise
compared to state-of-the-art is actually
landing up here this is a 99 dollar
three or four year old deck
and
you know it's almost the same as first
noise in this critical area so
definitely not competitive
so those are the dac measurements it's
got a headphone output and i believe a
lot of people buy this as a desktop
headphone amp and dac so let's measure
that um one measurement i perform is
that i've lowered the volume until it's
only 50 millivolts out there simulating
a reasonable volume on a very sensitive
in-ear monitor headphone
and
when i do that with this stack i get a
number of 82 db
which is only 13 and a half bits dynamic
range so worse than the cd format that
you're listening to and if i put that in
context of all the other dacs i've
tested dac amps that i've tested
you can see that state of the art is
over here around 95 here we're down at
82. so slightly above average but
you know not suitable for listening
with sensitive iems because
you know you might hear the hiss and
noise
from the stack
at high volumes so
you know anything below 90 is just not
good and at any price
uh to have it be a 14 000 amplifier
in a dac it's just not good i measured
the output
i was surprised how jagged it is okay
one channel of it may be the dac
problems i'll talk about but both of
them have this hump in here then they go
down and it's just
messy response look at the competitors
that i've tested again that same topping
dx
3 pro which is a 250 act look at how
predictable and ruler flat they are it's
nothing wiggly and weird is happening to
them but this one is just all over the
place likely because the noise profile
is changing depending on what it's doing
it almost gets to 100 milliwatts which
is my minimum standard for any desktop
products and
once you have 100 milliwatts you can get
reasonably good volume out of a let's
say sennheiser hd65x
type of products headphones um this one
barely gets there at 98. you know for
this price i expect it to be four or 500
milliwatts
so you can drive a wider set of
headphones than than
just the minimum standard
um
and similar story um you know same
wiggliness if we change the impedance to
just 30 to
33 ohm and we see the same wiggliness
the good news is that this distortion
sinks way down before it clips at one
watt so
as long as you stay below that nasty
clippiness
you do have a very low distortion device
at these higher volumes
i have finally i have a test where i
changed the load from 12 ohm all the way
up to 600 ohms and ideally all of these
graphs would land on top of each other
but they rarely do
meaning that as you decrease the
impedance you're stressing the dac more
and more and his voltage starts to drop
and his distortion starts to increase
but in grand scheme of things this is
not a concern
on this thing other than just low output
voltage of just five volts
now i know a lot some of the folks
reading looking at this video say wow
your measurements mean nothing all i
care about listen test um so i spent a
good bit of time listening i know rob
was to design this headphone uh sorry
this design this product loves a dan
clark stealth headphone which i also own
so i did listening tests with that
at low to medium volumes it sounded
excellent did it sound any different
than any other dac no absolutely not i
listen to the same tracks all the time
and with countless other amplifiers and
dax and i detected no
nothing magic popped out of it um but if
you did turn up the volume you were the
sound would initially get congested
whether you couldn't tell the
instruments apart as well and then
quickly becomes shrill and
sharp sounding in a really nasty way
meaning that the amplifier is entering
its clipping region and it simply can't
drive it this is a tough to drive
headphone you need a proper headphone
amplifier with for it to drive it at
high volumes and
cord dave is not it so if you insist on
using cord dave with this headphone i
suggest getting an external uh amplifier
like a top in a90 or something like that
that will run circles around this and
indeed i tested it with the topping nid
discrete and i could get to much higher
volumes with great clarity with zero
brightness increase and
and typical of when you crank the volume
actually sound improves the fidelity
improves the dynamic range improves so
much more enjoyable but uh be careful
you could damage your hearing
i then switched the sennheiser hd 650
which is a high impedance headphone
i
saw the same problem again at low the
medium volume it sounded fine sounded
good just uh you know as good as i
expect the sound to be but crank it up
and it gets shrill really bad um this
was without eq for hd650 and so it
doesn't have as much bass so the uh high
frequency
sharpness was there and really really
bothersome to me so
people say this sounds great i don't
know what their reference is i don't
know how they're doing their testing i
don't know what their hearing acuity is
they can't hear the shrillness and
brightness and
it's absolutely there and it's backed by
measurements that this amp is going to
clip in a very ugly way and it runs out
of power um but you know below that hey
it's a it's a great sounding dac and uh
you know i detected nothing that you
know that was a problem you know when
the headphone amp wasn't running out of
power
so where are we on this thing um the
company's has his tagline as dave stands
for digital to analog veritas uh in
extremis uh this extreme in in
truthfulness
well it is not extreme in truthfulness
to get to extreme truthfulness you need
to buy product that you know has least
amount of noise and distortion and those
fortunately cost five six hundred
dollars uh so what it costs to ship this
product to me probably if i bought it
you could buy a product that truly
objectively provably is there and
absolutely in sound quality listen to
them and those other pro attacks are
absolutely tremendous pair them up with
a great amplifier for another four or
five hundred dollars and you have
world-class sound
at a thousand dollars um
so you know if you're paying fourteen
thousand dollars for this unit know that
you need an external headphone hemp amp
or if you're using with speakers know
that you gotta screw around with tilting
it or something so you can see what the
heck is doing far away
so i went into this review expecting
that to find a
hugely performant deck
over designed and expensive i expected
it to be
perfect or near perfect unfortunately
what i found was
you know what 150 dollar product would
produce
and
um from that section and maybe a hundred
dollar amplifier i think a lot of 100
amplifiers headphone amps will
outperform it
so
i just don't understand this uh the
company clearly has an audio precision
analyzer the designer knows how to use
it but you know go look at their website
and you see none of the measurements
that i just showed you they have a few
spec numbers they're all a weighted
which means that a massive roll off in
low frequencies is applied
filtered before measuring it and that
would actually eliminate that noise
modulation that i was showing you
because it was showing the most in in
the low frequencies and so if you put a
high pass filter in there and uh like a
weighting is
you know you're not going to see that
yeah on this thing so
you know if company wants to object to
this i challenge them to run all these
things i'm happy to give them the
project file so they can replicate what
i have
one for one let's see if we get better
results as i mentioned there are other
reviews with similar that find similar
performance
they of course brush it under the rug
and you know say this is the best thing
since sliced bread i do not you know i
can't hide
you know what you see is what you get
and i have to treat every product the
same
so
there's just no way i can recommend this
product very disappointing the company
needs to go back to the drawing board
and just run these simple tests and go
in the design and clean it up
there's no reason any of this is
fundamental to the design of the product
these things could be fixed but clearly
they have and the company has been so
successful with this marketing of using
techno
buzzwords that
they haven't felt the pressure to
redesign
but they're just not competitive at any
price so disappoint
okay
see you in a future review bye